Man, I just hosted or didn't host Jesus. I warmed up for the VMs and I,
you know, you don't know who the hell anybody is. Well, I saw on news, I'm 34.
I saw on your Instagram. You said you bombed,
were you being cute or did you bomb?
I haven't bombed like that since the eighties. I mean, it was,
it was beyond the box. Did they introduce you? It was the whole,
the whole thing was.
I got a phone call two days before and I had to cancel a bunch of spots. Like,
do you want to warm up the VMs? I was like, Oh my God, good money. Radio city.
They'll pick up a limo, put a suit on the whole thing.
You'll get to see all the celebrities. Not realize that you don't know anymore.
So they go, all right, the show is at nine. We'll pick you up at six. You know,
they always do that. So I put my suit on, which I never do. I go down there,
they'd get a limo. I bring a lady with me like, Oh, I'm an impress her.
I like what you do with your suit. Let, let them tie and let it, I'm done.
Throw it over a beam. Exactly.
That's a Louis CK Rolex, by the way, allow me that. Oh, is that right? Yeah.
For the tour and for, so I do it.
So a you show up,
you get there like six 30 and all these people start filing in.
I'm in this holding pen for all the talent and I'm with the girl and she's
younger. She's in her twenties. So she's like,
that's the guy from one direction. That's BB. She's a big star girlfriend. Yeah.
I see. She's a big star in England. And I'm like,
I don't know who I am in a suit. They're all hot and hip.
I felt like a principal. Right. You know, I'm running around.
Nobody else was wearing suits. Nobody, nobody. They're all wearing crazy.
And I'm all. Kylie Jenner. It's a whole thing.
So I started getting kinda nervous. I started panicking. Like,
no one's telling me anything. No, one's going, Hey, you're on at this time.
This is what we need you to do. I'm getting no info.
And everybody's running around with a headset and a clipboard,
like chick nightmare, nightmare. They've been doing it 40 years.
Why can't they do it? Right. I don't get it. It's still a show. I feel when I.
Yeah. It's a, it's a circus down there. So now it's like,
I'm supposed to do 10 minutes and now it's like eight, 10, eight 30.
And I'm like, the show starts at nine. When are they going to have me on?
And now I'm starting to get that thing. Like maybe they'll just forget about me.
I'm hoping like, I'll get my paycheck. I showed up. They picked me up.
They'll just forget. And I'll just go home. And uh, so now it's like eight 58.
I'm like, I think I'm out of this. I tell you to be clean or no,
everything clean. Don't talk about Trump. Don't talk about kids in cages.
Like nothing in the news. So now it's like eight 58. I'm like, I think I,
I got out of this and then this fat guy comes in with cargo shorts and goes,
Mark Norman, the whole place turns I go, Hey, that's me. And he goes,
get over here. You're on. I go,
Oh my God brings me through the bowels of a radio city has million
people everywhere. Sorry. See you, man. Go through the motions.
But you went from I'm relieved. Like you finally had that moment of, okay,
it's not happening. Exactly. Instantly find out. Not only is it happening,
it's happening right now. No time to warm up. No time to think. Go. Yes.
And it's open bar down there.
So I've been hitting tequilas day for like three hours. So finally he's like,
come, he's pulling me through all these like half B celebrities and Bravo stars,
you know? And I get, get out there and you're just out there. Holy.
You're in radio city and I'm behind the curtain and this old guy with a,
with the headset goes, all right. So, uh, you know,
all the names of the artists, you've got the rap sheet and I was like rap sheet.
He goes, they didn't prep you. I was like, no. And he's like, well, what's this,
I'm holding a piece of paper. And he goes, is that the list of the artists?
I go, no, these are my jokes. And he goes jokes. Oh,
the gig. I thought I was going to be doing stand up. And he was like, stand up.
No, you're the hype man. You gotta get out there and talk about all the,
the acts you like and whose song is. So you hear warmup and you think warmup,
copy. They warm up. And they mean just like, man warmup.
Totally see Cardi B hand, like clap stuff. You know?
Like put your heads together on this side. No, this side, all that.
Like yes, like the t-shirt gun. Right? Exactly.
You're more than master of ceremonies completely. Then a comedian and you go,
Oh no, I don't know how to do that. I'm a piece of. Dry. I got nothing.
Although that's an easier thing. Yelling at people. This side of the room,
make noise. That side Bay to see that. If you hear the names,
that's easier to know the names though. He's not prep. Right. That's right.
And I've never done that for, I find that silly and retarded.
It stinks and it takes zero talent. And I've worked at my, I know my act,
my act works,
but not in this setting because it's half about Jews and Puerto Ricans and
whatever. So, so he goes, you just do a 10 minutes.
I'll come get you at nine. I'm like, come get me delight me.
He's like a light knew he didn't know anything.
We were all we're on two different planets.
Cause you're talking standup comedy and nobody is interested. No,
he doesn't care. So, uh, he's like, all right, you're all.
He just pushes me out there with a cordless mic.
So did you have the names of people? He never gave it. So I'm just,
he's just like, go, go. He's like shooing me out. And I just walk out there.
It's three tiers,
5,000 people smoking hot girls are all 21. You know,
all these hot guys and weird outfits,
like blazers with no shirt under it and crazy hair. Probably celebrities,
celebrities. So I just go on and go, how are you guys doing? I get like a,
you know, like no one cares. They're all. Selfieing,
they're all tweeting and looking at each other. And it's like smoking.
It's it's all the people you got into comedy to please. Like,
these are all high school people who made fun of me.
And now I'm trying to impress them again. And they hate me again.
Plus it's like, you're doing very well, but you're not like a celebrity.
Nobody. And they're excited to see celebrities on the stage. Yes.
And I'm just some dude in a suit. Right. I look like a, like a,
like the accountant of the VMs nobody's wearing suits. No,
nobody's wearing a suit. So I get out there and I'm like,
how are you guys doing it? I'm like, eh. And I'm like, all right.
So I kind of go into my act and that is they're like, what are you doing? Ah,
I'm embarrassed just at the tonight show like a week before this.
So I was feeling pretty good. Like I, I, I know what the kids like.
So I do a joke about selfies.
Cause they're all selfieing and even the setup they didn't even hear.
So then the punchline, I was like here at gums, nothing.
What's the punchline. What's the job. Got it. It works.
So I talked about how a women, they're all, they know how to look good.
So they take a self, they figure it out to take the selfie up here.
It's cause they know where the good sight lines are.
That's why women like tall guys.
Cause it's just some guy looking at you from your breast angle a hundred percent
of the time.
And that's why you don't like short guys because you're just a guy looking up at
you going look at the triple chin on this broad
[inaudible]. But that's what happened out there. Uh, that was,
that was just a car crash. This was like a train derailing story. Mark.
The hard part is when you, I don't.
Any relative experience,
but I remember one time do I think it was opening for Dyson,
the crowd was being really awful.
And I remember doing my opening thing and they didn't hear the set up,
but I needed a punchline. And you like, you're like,
this is going to bomb because they didn't hear my setup.
There's no way to fix this. This isn't my fault.
But there's nothing else I can tell you got to do sometimes is spend a few
seconds or a minute getting them focused and then sneak into
the opening joke. Do the stuff that you hate to do, you know,
just get them all going. If you can get it, it stinks. But you.
Probably wouldn't opening with that. You probably.
Thought that's exactly what you were doing.
Because since they're all taking selfies.
Right? Let me start with the, Oh, this guy's talking about selfies.
And he listened to, it was my game plan and the joke works.
It works at clubs though. It got zero. Like they didn't hear the setup,
like you said. And once they don't hear the setup, you're dead in the water.
And then they're just going, this guy sucks. And you're like, no,
you missed the setup. You cuts. This is what the joke got.
So what happened? What was the second thing you did after that? Didn't work.
So after that I'm like, all right, let's go in a, let's call an audible.
Let's go into crowd works. I go, who's from New York. Who's not from New York.
Who's from out of town. I'm doing all it's babysitting. That's all it is.
But that is the you got to do with that. And this guys who are good at that.
And it's an art, it's an art it's really.
Hard to do. Like I never on warmup guys who looked down on it.
That's a hard job, man.
Yeah. So I am dying. So now I'm just trying to like with people in the crowd.
And you know, I'm trying to stay true to myself as a guy walking by with this.
And then I go, Oh, I bought Coke from him. And everybody's like, why would,
why would you say that? And I'm like,
this guy looks like a pedophile and that Gallagher.
And so I'm bombing a bombing and J-Lo,
and a rod walked past me, literally like four feet away from me. And you know,
when you're bombing, you just reach for anything. So I go,
ah J-Lo and I just reach out for, and she goes
like hides and onstage because she had to cross, um,
there's like three different stages, like a mosh pit.
And I'm on one of the States. So she had to go over my stage to get to her area,
tried to kidnap chain. And you're not even supposed to look her in the eye,
let alone go. Gee, someone say that, Oh yeah. That's part of her writer.
Like that's her thing. You can't look her in the eye.
So I'm like reaching out for an, a Roz. It's like, Ooh, this poor guy.
And they both looked amazing by the way, but they didn't stop and talk to you.
Oh God, no, no. I was trying to at least wave to everybody. No.
And they went right to their Thrones and I was just like, Oh,
I used you at Jesus. So now I'm back to the girl, by the way,
she's watching this debacle. No, she's in the back. None of this is televised.
Thank God. Did it help you,
you with the audience when you reached out for J-Lo and she didn't even look at
you? Yeah, no. They were like, Oh, he's definitely a creep.
Like we hate you more. Now if Kayla had stopped by to get me some clout, right?
So now I'm bombing and bombing. I tried another joke that ah, shut up.
That goes right to hell. And eventually I'm just like,
I go into fight or flight mode where I go, look,
I don't know why I'm here either. What the am I doing? Why did they hire me?
This sucks. I hate this.
This is stupid were saying that you have to fill air. You got to fill time.
So you have to keep talking.
And I look over and the old guy with the headsets going get up,
get up and he's waving me in. And I was like, Oh thank God. I was like,
thank you everybody. And they're clapping. Like he's leaving God, he's leaving.
And I was like, ah, God, they hated me. And I go over to the guy and he goes,
he did eight and a half. I couldn't take it.
Nobody could take it. And they're like watching me in the booth, like,
who's this guy, what is this? And they pulled me off. Yeah.
They didn't prep me at all. And I got back to the, to the green room area.
And the girlfriend was like, well, what happened? That was like two seconds.
Y'all you're done already. I was like two seconds. I'm covered in sweat.
My pants are disheveled. My ties around my.
It was the whole picture right there. So I'm bombing.
This is my buddy Scott Rakowski. It was the only guy laughing. He does that.
He's the HQ guy. He's an old friend of mine,
but it was one guy laughing in the crowd. And it was him.
Was he laughing at your jokes or laughing at you? He was laughing at the bomb.
So he took a photo and it said hashtag hell gig. Oh,
Mark bombing at the VMs.
Funny that when that picture is taking take you're in the middle of your set.
Yeah. Yeah. That's how bad it was. He gets people's backs to you.
Those are the people behind me in the mosh pit area. They weren't even looking.
No, I was just playing to the, uh, the, the, the crowd looking forward.
They don't even, they didn't even turn around.
They were not going to look at the empty state. God, no,
they had the best seat in the house. They couldn't see me. Right. That was a,
that's a rough gig. Oh, it was bro. 5,000 people look how happy Seth is though.
He's dying. Scott, Scott. Sorry. Yeah. He's loving it. He loves it. I mean,
to be able to be bombing so bad that someone can take a selfie with you while
you're bombing. He literally stopped and looked. I love that.
You're posing for the photo. I would've, I would've sworn that.
That was after the gig. And you guys were both. I wish that's how bad it was,
where I was like, I need to fill 30 seconds with you coming up here. I was like,
take a photo of me, Scott. And he was like, all right. He came up and I'm like,
yeah, this guy, he loves it. I'm bombing. I'm just saying.
Do you know? I would literally.
Hey, however much a ticket costs to watch your 10 minutes. Oh,
my there was another lender dudes. Yes. Yeah.
He was in the crowd and he was filming me and he was like, this,
Diane out there, like he's tagging me. Uh,
it was like blurry and he couldn't hear it. But uh, I, I have it on my phone.
I want to see that footage. Do you more than that?
I want a different angle of the JFK assessment.
Oh God. Yeah. I would love to watch that. What at least killed on that
now? Did you stay and watch the VMA? No, I, uh, the girl was like,
we got to go out there, Ariana Grande's and I was like, all right.
And I stood in the back and I sucked down like four tequilas and lime.
And then we watched like 10 minutes of it and got the hell out of there.
She managed to leave her. No, no. She was like, this sucks.
We didn't have a seat. They didn't give me a seat. It was a whole thing.
We didn't exactly urgency. No, no, no. Maybe in the electric chair or something,
but a lot of that, that old guy felt sympathy for you.
There you go. Saw the crowd. I love a good bow.
What's better than a comedian friend bombing in front of five.
It is literally that's the way it was killed. It would have been like,
all right, cool. It's what you do anyway.
The fact that you had to bomb and swim and it was all yeah.
What swim in a suit. What an awesome gig to bomb it. Yeah, exactly.
That's perfect. It's supposed to vomit. I'm kind of supposed to bomb.
And I got the story the whole time going. I got a story from my podcast.
It'll be fun to tell. And um, I get to say I played radio city, which is like,
you know, always a dream. I've got Carnegie hall, radio city and uh,
Madison square garden. But when people go like, Oh, you played radio city,
how did it go?
Terrible bombed.
Bombed in front of 5,000. That's a bad gig though man gig.
But at the paycheck cleared and even, uh, Kevin Hart,
when he went up his jokes for doing.
K he wasn't killing when he was presenting the award with Tiffany has just a
tough kick for anybody.
No, Kevin jokes were good at, in the room,
but he was playing specifically to like a teenage audience.
Like his jokes would have done fine on MTV,
but when you took it out of that context and like,
you just watched the video as like, you know, Oh yeah.
34 year old people or older. Um, yeah, they didn't wait. They,
they don't work as, as comedy jokes. And there was no host there.
No one wants the host to say, no one wants to be there. Like cat Hart was there.
He got the out right after Jimmy found, got the hell out right out.
You just do your 10 minutes and you get out of there.
Is that why they don't have a host for sometimes nobody wants to do it.
It's like a it's antiquated. Like Sarah Silverman dev disease.
Did it Schumer did it? Kevin Hart did it at one point, but it's,
it's just a paycheck. Yeah. And you get to, you know,
be in front of a bunch of kids. So you stay a little more relevant.
Yeah. I'd love to do it.
Horribly bomb. Yeah. Oh yeah. Thank God that wasn't televised lobbying to do it.
You want a warm up or you want to host them. You want to host the VI.
You want to come up and host the VMs.
I want to warm up one here to prove that they will enjoy me and then.
Maybe they can get chip. That would be a funny host.
I would love it.
Jim would just go up there and make references to like the late three pop
culture, things that he knows,
like he make reference to push it T and then you go to Sean Paul,
and then he fall into the omen three go. Well, no,
I have to go to the bathroom badly. All right, well, let's take a break. Um,
you're going to go, is it a one or two? It's a three
combinations gotta come in. Someone's mouth. I'm on.
A podcast.
Is Tuesdays with stories of Mark Norman comedy.com.
Right?